yes I work at Erickson in Stockholm
Ericson basically builds the mobile
infrastructure so making sure that
everyone's phones can connect to the
internet there's many interesting
machine learning challenges connected to
that but I also pursue a PhD in the
field of topological data analysis and
that's what I will talk about
today because last fall I was feeling
that I sort of needed to take a step
back and be able to explain a little bit
what I was doing and what the field is
about and how it fits into the larger
machine learning ecosystem and this
presentation came came out of that and
has been so far a good way to sort of
start
questions and discussions around this
topic for with people from from
different fields so let's see how it
goes today and I want to start by
talking about baboons and geometry so if
we present a few pictures like these to
a baboon and ask it to point out the
outlier it will not be able to point at
this picture yet we as humans recognize
that there's something different with
this picture because it has a different
shape a different geometric regularity
but how do we even ask a baboon
something so researchers can test the
intelligence of baboons piloting them
answer questions on a touchscreen like
this and baboons are pretty smart they
can a is pretty Advanced cognitive tests
and they can recognize basic shapes like
these ones
but somehow they seem to have a blind
spot when it comes to recognizing
geometric irregularities such as
distinguishing the rectangle from the
less regular polygons in this example
whereas we as humans on the other hand
may seem to have what could be called a
native sense of geometry and these
researchers went to quite some length to
to prove that it's actually a native
property so they gave this kind of test
to Children kindergarten they give this
kind of test to people from different
countries to people from an indigenous
people just to make sure that this is
something native and not just something
we acquire through culture or formal
education
so if you're ready to to believe that
um
that the geometry is something that sets
the intelligence of humans apart from
from that of other animals and maybe
long-term goal is to build human level
AIS then maybe geometry can be
interesting
so what about machine learning What If
instead of training baboons we train
neural networks so what these
researchers did was to take a
pre-trained convolutionary network
and they passed this kind of pure
geometric shapes through the network and
looked at where he ended up in the
internal representation space in the
embedding space
for example checking if they fed similar
shapes would it end up in in the same
area of the internal representation
space for example and that was not the
case and maybe indicates that shape is
not really used in the way at least
those kind of networks organize their
internal information maybe they don't
have any concept of shape
and that seems to be corroborated by
quite a lot of research if we have a cat
then we give it the skin of an elephant
then
I don't know about you but I would still
think of this as a cat that sort of
tries to disguise as an elephant but the
network is happy to believe that this is
an elephant and that indicates a strong
bias towards considering texture and not
considering shape when making its
decisions
now in many applications that's kind of
bias is fine but I'll try to argue that
sometimes we actually want the machine
learning algorithms to consider shape
and if we want that then one way is to
teach them a little bit of math
so in maps shapes are studied in the
field of geometry that we may remember
from elementary school so in in Geometry
we look at properties like distances
curvature angles properties that are
very sensitive to changes in the
underlying object
so if we start with the ball in the top
left corner here and we successively
deform it in small steps and actually
all these steps we represent the change
in the geometry of the object
but shapes are also studied in the field
of topology and in topology we look
Instead at properties that don't change
even if we twist or stretch or bend the
space so we get properties that are very
insensitive very Global but that's also
very robust for example in this picture
it's only in these steps that we have a
change in the topology of the object
only if we tear it apart or puncture it
so geometry has been studied for a few
thousand years and topology for at least
a couple of hundred years before there
were any
computers around
but more recently there has been a focus
on actually developing algorithms to to
try to compute geometric and topological
properties
and in the field of topological data
analysis TDA that we'll talk about today
we look more specifically at um spaces
that arise in the context of data
analysis so in other words we want to
talk about the shape of data
and while topological data analysis has
topology in the name the methods used in
this field really serve as sort of an
interface between topology and geometry
so it can reason about golf local and
Global properties
so in at some basic level we try to type
into this ancient knowledge in math and
see what happens when we adapt it to to
data to machine learning and maybe
that's something that could be
interesting more generally if I were to
generalize a little bit I would say that
the algorithms that we use and love
today are very impressive and built on a
very interesting math but maybe built on
math from relatively few Fields
relatively few mathematical pillars
and it's kind of interesting to think
what what could happen if we include a
little bit of map from from new fields
in this in this mix
and that is something that
the WASP research program is exploring
it's a very ambitious research program
that we have in Sweden around Ai and one
of the things that they are exploring is
this intersection between math and Nai
so if you want to do research in machine
learning come to Sweden check out this
program
but
for now let's um
let's talk about what we mean when we
talk about the shape of data so in the
introduction we looked at pure geometric
shapes but of course in reality we would
like to be able to say something about
the shape of real data what's the shape
of this point Cloud what's the shape of
the second Point cloud
can we compare them maybe to the left I
have a training set and to the right I
have a set of simulated samples
generated from the training set and I
want to compare them
maybe intuitively these two point clouds
to the left and to the right don't look
so similar and these maybe look more
similar because they have a common
clustering structure but how do I know
which properties to look for and how can
I compare Point clouds that may not have
the same coordinate system maybe not the
same number of points or the same
dimension
so here's an example of a method used in
TDA so we'll start with a point cloud
and we'll take it to be in two
dimensions for the sake of the
illustration
next we will select the threshold and
then we will connect all the points that
are a distance smaller than the
threshold doing so we get the graph and
then we just count the number of
connected components in that graph
so let's take an example if we start
with a low threshold then no points are
connected yet so we have nine connected
components for the nine individual
points
but if you increase the threshold that
then we have that some points are now
being connected
and we have in the in the graph five
connected components
to increase the threshold we have more
points being connected and fewer
components and in the end there will
just be one big component because all
the points will be connected
and this information about the
connectedness of the space that all
thresholds can be summarized in the in
the underground
so if we looked at the low threshold
that corresponds to the vertical dashed
line here and it intersects nine
horizontal lines for the nine components
that were live at that time
for the next threshold it intersects
five lines so the dendrogram allows us
to see for each threshold how many
components are alive but also how
smaller components merged into larger
ones if we follow the tree structure
and connectedness is an example of a
topological property that was one of the
examples in the introduction we had this
ball and then we split it in two and
merged it back together and this is a
fairly common recipe for methods in this
field that we take a space like a point
cloud and we look at it at different
thresholds and for each threshold we
build a graph or sometimes another kind
of combinatorial object but something
from which we can read out the
topological property so we get this
multi-scale multi-freshold view of our
space where we see how topological
properties vary as we vary a threshold
and maybe the dendrogram looks familiar
and maybe that's because it's also used
in hierogical clustering where it's
often used to select the threshold so
and then once we have a threshold we can
go back to the input space to the point
cloud and we can look at the
corresponding components only there we
don't call it components we call it
cluster so we get a clustering for each
threshold
and that can be useful but in in TDA we
would rather want to say something about
the whole Space so maybe let's keep the
whole dendrogram as it seems to contain
quite Rich information about the
connectedness of the space
and then maybe if we have two spaces we
can sort of compare them something about
the shape something about the
connectivity through their undergrounds
it turns out that we just have to take
one more step before we can do that and
convert this into another mathematical
object called the barcode which will
track when topological properties appear
and for how long they persist
for example we had one component here
that appeared at threshold zero
persisted for a little while until it
was merged into a larger component
and so we get a short bar for that
same thing here for a second component
and if we do this for the whole the
underground we get a whole set of bars
and the barcode and this is something we
have a distance on an optimal transport
type distance
so that now if we have two spaces we can
compute the identograms and then the
barcodes and we can compare something
about their their shape about their
connectedness through the barcodes
and this is one one example for one
topological properties and the methods
in TDA can be can also be parametrizable
to capture different aspects of geometry
and if they are included in in your
networks then these parameters can be
learned Based on data
sometimes we don't want to extract some
shape information from data but we would
rather want to control the shape of some
data Maybe of some embedding space that
can be done too and finally what we took
the example of a point Cloud the methods
can apply to more General types of input
such as graphs and images
but now for the remainder of the
presentation let's look at some examples
where we can use these these methods
so our brains are full of neuronal and
glia tree cells such as the ones in this
picture and your scientists need ways to
compare the shape of these cells and
relate their shape to the role they play
in the nervous system
and for example in the project
to which I collaborated that was driven
by a team of your scientists at IST
Austria and that we collaborated to from
kth
we looked at the shape of microglia
cells in the in the brains of mice and
whether for example that shape differs
for cells that come from different brain
regions or for healthy versus disease
mice and so on
but to do all these things we first have
to take these physical biological things
and convert them into Data
now we could open the brains of some ice
and make some measurements maybe I count
the number of branches or I measure how
long they are I could also put these
things together in a feature vector
or maybe I take a picture of the whole
cell maybe in 3D so that I get a voxel
representation of it
now the first approach might not be rich
enough to
measurements that I choose might not be
the ones that best reflect the
variability between cells but the second
approach might be too rich it might be
too high dimensional and it does not
include the prior knowledge that the
neuroscientists have about these objects
for example that they are invariant to a
lot of things translation rotation Etc
but also for example at the thickness
that we see in this picture is mostly
the result of the handling done in the
laboratory and is not so meaningful
biologically
so inferior in your network could learn
this aspect if it has a lot of label
data and the right structure but in
general by incorporating some kind of
invariances some kind of Prior
topological priorities in this case we
can often make training more more
efficient and maybe even the resulting
Network more more robust
but at an even more fundamental level
somehow even if you represent the data
with a small feature vector or with a
very large Vector representing it as an
image we somehow still make the same
assumption that the data can be
represented as a vector at all that it
is euclidean data
and that is not always the the only
choice so in this project we
model the data topologically so we look
at how the the branching structure
changes from the as we move from the
extremity towards the roots of these
cells so in the introduction we looked
at
um
connectedness of a point Cloud as we
varied distance and here it's it's the
same but we have a tree and sort of the
threshold this is how we reveal this
tree starting from the extremity moving
towards the root of the tree
but we get the same kind of descriptor
the barcode for the for the tree and
that is the lens for which we see the
data and it's a mathematical object but
it's not a euclidean one and that's
something that I found interesting
moving into this kind of projects that
um sometimes we've um with some app we
can come up with new new types of data I
think data is
anything on which we can have a language
something in which we can reason in some
precise way so if you give me a class of
objects and you can measure distances
between those objects and maybe you can
add two objects together maybe even have
a lot of large numbers and things like
that if you have these things or even
just some of these things then I would
say that what you have is is data and
and um if you want you want what you
want to capture is sort of the the shape
the morphology of some underlying
objects then representing it with
methods from TDA can be can be
interesting and in that sense this can
be related to the trend of geometric
deep learning that sort of encourages us
to look Beyond euclidean geometries
but once we have data then we can do
data analysis and just to take an
example here we have to the left
a dimensional introduction of these
cells seen as a shooter shape and we can
compare that to the physical layout of
these cells in the different brain
regions just as an
so let's stay in the brain here we have
a picture of a neural circuit and let's
task ourselves with delimitating the
individual neurons in this picture so in
other words we have an image
segmentation task
so in the standard image segmentation
task we may have a bunch of pictures
coupled with their segmentation masks so
a human annotator has taken these
pictures and colored the different
regions corresponding to the different
neurons with different colors
then we can feed our pictures through a
neural network can have different
architectures but that will output a
probability or a classification for each
pixel saying which segment it belongs to
and that's something we can compare to
the ground truth and Constructor loss
functional but let's think about what
the maybe sort of classical loss
functions
will encourage the network to learn
so it's a purely local loss function in
this case like we go pixel by pixel we
look at whether it was correctly
classified and then we just take a sum
or an average
and so there's nothing in this loss
function that can account for more
Global properties like the shape of
these segments so maybe the neural
network will output a picture that looks
like this that it thinks looks good
because it has a low loss and most
pixels are correctly classified but to
our human eye it might not look
satisfactory because it has this
fragmented shape with a few pixels
belonging to the different classes here
and there
so what we would like is perhaps is a
way to tell on your network to not just
care about things pixel by pixel but
also care about the shape of the segment
for example 2 should have a few
consistent segments such as in the
ground truth and not this fragmented
Behavior here and that is something that
can be encoded with the methods from TDA
so if we produced one of these barcodes
for the ground roof and another one for
the prediction of the neural network
then this can be compared and included
in the loss function of the neural
network so that the new network can be
penalized if it would produce outputs
that deviate topologically from the from
the ground truth
maybe arriving at pictures that look
more more like this
so for last example let's look now at um
um the shape of maybe the the internals
of a neural network or an embedding
space
um so I think embedding spaces are
everywhere in in machine learning even
if we think of a classical
classification problem we can see it for
that lens like what we want is to
construct an embedding space where the
different embeddings forms clusters
corresponding to the classes or if we
have a
embeddings of images like in the
previous talk then we want the distance
between those embeddings to somehow
correspond to how similar we perceive
them with our human eyes so maybe
most problems in machine learning can be
seen as sort of constructing an
embedding space with the right geometry
and maybe that can be a promising area
for for TDA as well because it's sort of
all about all about the shape of these
kind of spaces so if we have an auto
encoder
then we have an embedding space in the
in the bottleneck here because it really
include it will contain
low dimensional representations of the
input that will in some sense contain as
much information as possible from the
original input
and the classical autoencoder may be
trained with a reconstruction loss so we
just take a sample we pass it through
the network we look at what we get at
the other end and then we just compare
the input to the reconstruction
and similar to the previous example this
will be a purely local loss so there's
nothing in this loss function that can
account for Global aspects that can
account for the shape of the embedding
space
so
if we would have a data set that would
be in in three dimension and just
happens to have the shape of a mammoth
and don't ask me why and we would want
to sort of flatten this Mammoth we want
to reduce its Dimension to to
then these are two propositions
which are both legitimate and are
Optimal Solutions even to some
dimensionality reduction optimization
problem but the problem has been
formulated differently maybe in the
middle
um there is only this kind of local loss
function and to the right topological
loss component similar to the previous
example has been included to try to make
sure that the
the shape of the embedding space is
somehow aligned to the to the shape of
the original space in this case maybe
just making sure that the flattened
elephant is still connected as the as
the original elephant was
so whether this matters or not depends
on the applications but um I think in
your networks will never be smarter than
the loss function we were assigned to
them and but if we want them to actually
consider something about
um the shape we can tamper with that
loss function
maybe with methods from from TDA to um
to encourage the network to consider
these things or we can already at the
stage of modeling our data incorporate
some of these invariances
but none of this would
would not be worth so much if we
couldn't do it in in Python so let me
just talk a little bit about
some python libraries where this can can
be used
so if you want to
compute
maybe barcodes of some data I would
recommend you to start with with joto
TDA so which interfaces nicely with
scikit-learn so for example we can build
pipelines where maybe we extract
barcodes from some data and then we feed
them to some of the machine learning
algorithms in inside kit learn and
doing something like the example in
introduction can be as easy as this
initializing a persistence object that's
kind of how we see the data space for
Which combinatorial object
and the distance that's how that's the
distance we use to merge the points
together including distance and then we
can just if it Transformer away from
there if we have a point Cloud PC
if however we want to include these
methods in a new network then I would
recommend to look at
torch topological
if you're using pytorch and something
like the last example could be done in
in this snippet this comes straight from
the great documentation of this package
so if we assume that we have we already
have an autoencoder model that we pass
in to the Constructor here
and then we also initialize our
persistence object as in the previous
example and we also choose a loss
function that is compatible with these
with these barcodes then in the forward
pass we assume that we get a bunch of
high dimensional vectors maybe our data
set or a large batch of it we pass it
through the autoencoder model to get the
low dimensional
embeddings
we compute the barcodes for the
originals and the low dimensional
embeddings and then we can apply a loss
and what is interesting here is that
when we then call backward to get the
back the back propagation started it was
sort of back propagate all the way
through the barcode to the data so in
this case to the low dimensional
embeddings so that in the next step of
the optimizer this will be changed to
sort of
have the right
shape according to the to the loss
function
so that's all I had
thanks for listening hope to take some
questions
[Applause]
thanks a lot yes there was a great talk
and surprisingly a little
um mathematical algebra
we we do have some questions
um
what can one say about the void around
the points can one detect outliers
yes it's it's an interesting direction
to
um
Maybe
an outlier is something that sort of
changes the
the topology of the space in in some
sense and then this methods can be
can be an interesting direction to to
detect that to sort of yeah as an
alternative to
maybe other anomaly detections maybe
that was the theory of the question
thank you how do you take a segmented
neuron image and get the points of
interest to create the TDA barcode
um
right so that's relates to this one yeah
so so this in this case it's um
well it is
we can see that um
so it's a little bit different from the
point Cloud example but we can see that
these segments basically well we can see
the image as a
as a graph and with the
um
or under the the different
segments as as graphs and seeing the the
connectivity of of them in a sense so
that's sort of what's going to be to be
optimized in this in this example
a little bit connected to that how do
you handle these bar codes in code what
kind of object do they resemble
yeah so it's a
it's a set of
of points in the plane basically
um
so so it can be it can be easily encoded
but the US utilities with the distance
which is not
um you know the euclidean distance but
something that has to work with these
sets that can also have different
cardinality different number of of bars
but that's something that these packages
can handle can compute these distances
and so on
more questions coming in do you think it
could be applied to Medical images EG
x-rays
yeah I haven't haven't seen really an
examples in that area but um
somehow yeah I think nature likes
geometry and anthropology and likes to
create these kind of patterns that are
sometimes possible to to capture with
this with these methods and another
interesting one regarding use cases how
can topological encoders be used for
human post detection other computer
vision applications
um I have not three really seen any any
example for for human pulse
detection
okay
um
so let's see I think we can do some more
is the data used usually in the form of
Point clouds
um voxels rasterize data
yes so it can be
it can be Point clouds it can be um
images or voxels or or graphs or
basically
um
there's a sort of a modeling Choice
there
to to encode these into these kind of
combinatorial objects that we have a
filtration on so there's also a level of
possible Innovation at that level but
yeah most common I guess is
images or 3D images and
point clouds graphs time series as well
it's a it's a growing area of things
like that
okay now a nice one how do you choose
proper activation function for this case
a proper activation function
[Music]
so the
yeah so the activation function
um like in the Indian Network can be
this would typically be maybe the the
first layer of a neural network either
to to extract something or to
control the shape of of the input and
then you can compose it to
more classical neural network layers and
have your your classical
activations in in the architecture so
you know last one would you be able to
isolate classify logical or physical
structures for example in apostrophe
composed of dots laser detection from a
global noise I don't get the question
sounds interesting yes please come and
talk to me about it okay okay okay so
maybe maybe you can ask it later
so thanks a lot for being here
um that was a really interesting talk
and we now have a coffee break and if
you have more question please stay here
I think Jens will be around and I think
you can share the slides can't you yes
true okay thanks a lot